[Music]
so a lot of you've been asking how do i
learn how to do visual effects to learn
visual effects you have to sit down and
say what effect do i want to do you
choose a single effect and you start
from there
let's say you want to do lightsabers
it's as simple as going to google and
typing how do i do lightsabers
how do how do i set up a green screen
how do i do a lightsaber how do i do
physics in my 3d program
all that stuff is online or in the
program manual
it's just about having the realization
that all that knowledge is actually out
there alright guys here's a list of
websites that'll help you learn how to
do visual effects first off if you want
to know about after effects check out
videocopilot.net if you want to learn
about 3ds max check out 3dtotal.com they
got a bunch of good tutorials in there
also read the manual got a lot of good
stuff in there if you have questions
about like video formats editing
software things like that check out the
creative cal forums what else you got
saying uh boojoo motion tracking things
like that uh youtube is actually one of
the best resources for this obviously
the manual is the ultimate resource for
any of these things and a lot of people
tend to look past this just because it's
intimidating by the amount of pages
whatever it's the best way to learn
anything yep if you guys have questions
about like how to render things
correctly how to get good lighting
google master zaps mental ray tips
everything you need to know there
manual yeah read the manual guys
[Music]
that's the default question the default
answer to everything not email us
so a lot of people ask about going to
school for visual effects
and i think that's not really the right
approach to take because visual effects
is kind of like a subset it's like going
to school to learn photoshop like you
don't go to school or in photoshop you
go to school to learn how to be a
photographer and photoshop is one of
your tools if you want to do visual
effects start doing it now there's a
billion tutorials online that are going
to teach you more than any class on
after effects at a college what do you
think the best school for visual effects
is
honestly i don't know what the best
school for visual effects is because i
didn't go to a visual effects school and
uh you don't need to to learn visual
effects at all but that's not to say
there's no use in them because honestly
uh going through formal training or
going through a school or university to
learn it is
also a pretty good route if you just
find yourself struggling and
not finding the information you want to
learn
they can provide you know a lot of great
resources towards that however there is
one thing you can get out of college
that is a really good art program
learning a lot of the actual fundamental
art training and fine art training is
going to guide you quite a bit in
learning and understanding how light
works how the world works and that all
that all feeds into visual effects
learning how to do motion tracking you
don't need to go to school for that
there's a youtube video that you can
watch for that you don't need to pay 30
000 a year to learn how to do motion
tracking but learning
like learning how to composite something
learning how to match perspectives
you're going to get all that if you
start doing drawing training figure
studies all those kind of things that
you can get from a college the other
thing you get from a college is another
thousand people that want to make movies
also you get a community so there's
certain like pros to go into college but
there's certain things that you might be
looking for in a school that actually
aren't really there
[Music]
you